let's get real here this is america on a
plate fried rice two eggs a giant steak
ketchup syrup chili oil salt pepper a1
steak sauce sriracha this is seriously
one of the best meals i've ever had in
my life
my name is shirley ying and i'm the
manager of uncle john's cafe originally
the owner started it as a american diner
and a chinese owner purchased the
business so we incorporated chinese food
in it you can get pancake or yeah
unconventional with the chow mein it
just works this diner is my childhood
because that's what i would eat growing
up we're gonna serve you guys uncle
john's stick and eggs we start off with
a cut of new york steak it's about eight
ounces we marinate it with a little bit
of soy sauce garlic salt salt and pepper
and it's eleven dollars eleven dollars
and it's not only the steak it comes
with two eggs however you like it and it
also comes with a side and toast how can
you provide it at this price we have
other items on the menu that helps
outweigh the cost of the steak for a
diner you need the steak and eggs and
it's just on the menu because people
want steak and eggs for breakfast